and greg she has been addressing the
court so what has she said so far
well she started by saying that she had
a lot to say and it's very clear in the
last 20 minutes or so that she has
expressed a lot of
the anger and hurt that she feels about
what's happened to her over the last few
years i've got to say her fans are
listening in to a feed of the court
and you can hear their reaction every
now and then to what she says she says
that
other people have done a good job in
exploiting her life and that's why she
wants to speak
now she doesn't think she's been heard
in court before she said she talked
about
threats to to tour talking about an
involuntary hospitalization about a
medication that she says
was switched without her knowledge she
also said that
people who have done this to her as she
said as she said
should not be able to simply walk away
and compare their treatment
to that of what's done to people who are
sex trafficked and she said i didn't
know i could petition the court to
terminate
this conservatorship which of course she
can she says she's been forced to lie
and say she was happy when she wasn't
and then she said this it is my wish and
dream
for all of this to end i want my life
back and she is continuing to give
that evidence to this conservative
hearing
later greg milam thank you